when I think about who is a trailblazer  in Opera for me it's Marian Anderson she  was the first african-american to sing  at the Metropolitan Opera and without  her I'm not here  [Music]  the beauty of her sound is something  that is and it's an unmistakable sound  but also when she was having the burden  but of her career it was during a time  where she couldn't sing everywhere she  wanted to say when the DAR wouldn't have  her sing in Washington Eleanor Roosevelt  had other plans and that's when she sang  on the steps of the Lincoln Memorial  [Music]  it gives me chills my message to the  next generation of artists is that it's  about the work and the finished product  may look easy but it's it's not and if  you don't enjoy working on the craft and  it's not for you